[Música]
según medios polacos misiles rusos
impactaron sobre Polonia y mataron a dos
personas es la primera vez en la Guerra
de Ucrania que armamento ruso cae sobre
un país de la otan esto el día que Rusia
lanzó el mayor bombardeo sobre Ucrania
desde que empezó la invasión los ataques
sobre la infraestructura energética
causan apagones en todo el país
Este martes 15 de noviembre de 2022 la
humanidad alcanzó los 8000 millones de
personas con enormes retos para nuestra
especie el mayor de todos combatir las
desigualdades materiales de derechos y
de oportunidades que marcan nuestras
vidas en función del lugar del mundo en
el que nacemos
las 20 potencias del planeta se reúnen
en Indonesia en la Cumbre del g20 la
invasión rusa de Ucrania y los impactos
del conflicto sobre la economía global
marcan la agenda impulsada por
Washington
buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarlos
comenzamos esta edición con una noticia
que enciende las alarmas de la comunidad
internacional según reporta la agencia
de noticias asociar Express un bombardeo
de misiles rusos en la red eléctrica de
Ucrania hizo que la guerra se extendiera
a los países vecinos dos cohetes rusos
habrían golpeado a Polonia en una en una
zona cerca de la frontera con Ucrania y
causado la muerte de dos personas
recordemos que Polonia es país miembro
de la otan insistimos esta sería la
primera vez desde el inicio de la
invasión que armamento ruso cae de un
país miembro de la alianza atlántica el
incidente se habría producido en el
marco del mayor bombardeo ruso sobre
Ucrania desde que empezó la ofensiva la
otan investiga los hechos que Rusia
niega mientras el gobierno de Polonia
reunió al Consejo de Seguridad nacional
escuchemos al portavoz del gobierno
polaco socios
debido a la situación de crisis el
Primer Ministro Mateos morogbiatsi en
consulta con el presidente andrey duda
ordenó una reunión en la oficina de
seguridad nacional con miembros del
comité de seguridad y defensa nacional
se proporcionará cualquier información
que se presente hoy en el comité más
tarde y si es necesario Se pondrá a
disposición del público tanto como sea
posible les informaremos sobre estos
eventos hago un llamado a no publicar
información no confirmada hasta entonces
la comentaremos e informaremos después
de la reunión que se llevará a cabo
como decíamos Rusia volvió a bombardear
todo el territorio ucraniano las
autoridades de kiev aseguran que Rusia
lanzó Este martes un centenar de misiles
provocando apagones a lo largo y ancho
del país las autoridades ucranianas
alertan que la situación energética es
crítica a raíz de la ola de ataques
especialmente en las regiones Norte y
central en la capital kiev los
bombardeos impactaron sobre un edificio
Residencial y al momento se reporta un
fallecido
se lanzaron 85 ataques con misiles
contra Ucrania contra nuestras ciudades
principalmente en la infraestructura
energética está claro lo que quiere el
enemigo no logrará su objetivo todavía
pueden haber alrededor de 20 ataques
Porvenir por lo que les pido a todos que
se cuiden y permanezcan en los refugios
por un tiempo sé que los ataques
cortaron el suministro eléctrico en
muchas ciudades de nuestro país estamos
trabajando restauraremos todo
sobreviviremos a todo Gloria a Ucrania
lo estás haciendo muy bien
según las proyecciones de Naciones
Unidas hoy martes 15 de noviembre de
2022 ya somos 8.000 millones las
personas que habitamos la tierra el
mayor reto para la humanidad es combatir
las injusticias que marcan el desarrollo
de nuestras vidas en función del lugar
del mundo en el que nacemos
desigualdades materiales de acceso a
recursos a oportunidades de derechos y
de impacto de la crisis climática sobre
nuestros hogares
un nuevo hito para la humanidad Este
martes nació en República Dominicana
Damián qué Naciones Unidas considera el
habitante número 8.000 millones una
celebración de la diversidad para la ONU
pero con advertencias lo recién llegados
a la tierra encuentran un planeta en
emergencia miles de millones de personas
están luchando cientos de millones se
enfrentan al hambre e incluso a la
hambruna números
récords están en movimiento en busca de
oportunidades y alivio de la deuda y las
dificultades Las Guerras y los desastres
climáticos en 2023 India superará a
China como el país más poblado el
gigante asiático se enfrenta a un grave
declive de su tasa de natalidad y más de
la mitad del aumento de la población se
concentrará principalmente en África
concretamente Las Naciones subsaharianas
contribuirán con más de la mitad del
crecimiento de la población mundial
previsto hasta 2050 en Nigeria por
ejemplo la Edad Media es de 17 años
la creciente población en Nigeria se
debe a que no controlamos nuestra tasa
de crecimiento
si miras al norte son libres de casarse
con hasta cuatro esposas y cada esposa
puede tener tantos hijos como quiera
desde el sur sabemos que por las
dificultades económicas la gente tiende
a no tener demasiados hijos
el estudio de la ONU también refleja que
para 2050 habrá un 10% más de personas
mayores de 65 años con fuertes impactos
en Europa
somos ocho mil millones pero en nuestro
país Italia el crecimiento es cero nos
creemos que los jóvenes de hoy ya no
pueden formar una familia por una serie
de problemas con un crecimiento
ralentizado desde 1950 se espera que
2080 sea la década en la que el mundo
alcance su pico de habitantes con más de
10.400 millones de personas
en la actualidad dos tercios de la
población mundial vive en un país o área
donde la fecundidad es inferior a 2,1
nacimientos por mujer el nivel
considerado óptimo para garantizar El
reemplazo generacional en Bali empezó
oficialmente la Cumbre del g20 lo
representantes de los 20 países más
ricos del mundo trabajan en una
declaración conjunta en el borrador la
mayoría de Estados condenan la invasión
rusa de Ucrania sin embargo el texto
refleja las distintas posiciones entre
los miembros del grupo entre los cuales
se encuentran Estados Unidos India y
China así como Rusia
vale Indonesia fue el destino del g20 la
reunión de los líderes de las
principales economías del mundo en la
agenda de la primera jornada un tema
opaco a los demás la guerra en Ucrania
presente hasta en el discurso inaugural
bien
ser responsable Aquí también significa
que debemos terminar la guerra
si la guerra no ha terminado será
difícil que el mundo avance tomo Forward
Y es que la mayoría de los países
asistentes como Estados Unidos o Francia
firmarán una declaración conjunta de
condena de la Guerra de Ucrania un tema
que preocupa a todos los invitados en
una ocasión en la que el presidente de
Ucrania voló densky ha aprovechado para
pedir que las naciones del g20 apoyen su
plan para acabar con el conflicto con
propuestas como la creación de un
tribunal especial para condenar la
agresión de Rusia que está reconozca la
integridad territorial de Ucrania o el
intercambio total de prisioneros y habló
de un g-19 en una Clara exclusión de
Rusia
estoy convencido de que ahora es el
momento de que la guerra destructiva
rusa debe y pueda detenerse
algo que Rusia representada por el
canciller ser gay en labrov en la Cumbre
interpretó como la negativa de Ucrania
al inicio de las negociaciones
todos los problemas están en la parte
ucraniana que se niega a categóricamente
a mantener cualquier conversación y
viene con condiciones obviamente reales
e inadecuadas para esta situación
[Música]
una situación que se ve con preocupación
desde el g20 que ya ha asegurado va a
firmar una declaración de condena de
cualquier amenaza de uso de armas
nucleares por parte de cualquier bando
en Irán Mañana se cumplen dos meses de
la muerte de maxam Mini bajo custodia de
la policía de la moral Este martes
empezó una huelga de tres días que aúna
el movimiento desatado por la muerte de
la joven kurdo iraní con la
conmemoración de las protestas masivas
de 2019 en las que la fuerza pública
también mató a cientos de personas
nuestra corresponsal Catalina Gómez
ángel con los detalles desde Teherán
esta huelga nacional que ha sido
convocada por tres días y que comenzó
hoy no solamente está llamada a recordar
a maxam Y esa joven kurda que hace ya
dos meses fue detenida por la policía la
moral y dos días después falleció en un
hospital de Teherán sino especialmente
para recordar a miles de personas que
hace tres años en el 2019 en esta misma
fecha en el mes de avant como se conoce
por el calendario persa salieron a
protestar por el aumento repentino del
precio de la gasolina y En aquel momento
la represión si bien no se sabe si fue
mayor si fue mucho más concentrada en
pocos días y bastante violenta algunas
versiones hablan de más de 300
fallecidos y otras como la que citó la
agencia de noticias routers que hablaba
con Fuentes gubernamentales locales
gente que habló fuera of the récord
hablaba de 1.500 muertos en aquel
momento así que querían recordar a estas
personas estuvimos dando vueltas por
Teherán y vivimos parte de los sectores
comerciales parcialmente cerrados
también veíamos mucha gente caminando en
la calle intentando unirse y cuando se
unían pues cantaban esos eslóganes que
se han convertido en símbolos de estas
protestas incluido muerte al dictador y
también veíamos muchas mujeres sin el
velo como acto de protesta y está huelga
es importante para quienes están en las
calles Desde hace dos meses porque una
de las críticas que hacían al sector
económico es que no se habían arriesgado
a apoyar estas protestas la indignación
cada vez es mayor la rabia es cada vez
mayor pero muchas personas se preguntan
Cómo poner en riesgo sus negocios o su
vida económica por algo que no saben qué
va a pasar así que para quienes
protestan lo que sucedió hoy ha sido
bastante importante
en México integrantes de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos junto
a la relatora especial para México
presentaron un tercer informe del
mecanismo de seguimiento al caso
Ayotzinapa en el que advirtieron que si
las autoridades que investigan el caso
no tienen Independencia no Habrá
justicia recordemos que se trata del
caso de los 43 estudiantes de esa
desaparecidos de un colegio en el Estado
de Guerrero en 2014 los detalles en el
reporte de nuestro corresponsal en
Ciudad de México Mario carbonell la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos presentó el tercer informe del
mecanismo especial de seguimiento al
asunto Ayotzinapa en el documento la
cidh expresa preocupación por algunos
aspectos por ejemplo la demora
injustificada en la aplicación de
órdenes de aprehensión y reiteran su
inquietud por la cancelación de 21
órdenes de atención que ya habían sido
libradas también advierten que a pesar
de que existe un contexto político
favorable al más alto nivel en la
alusión a la apertura que hay por parte
del ejecutivo persiste mucha resistencia
para entregar información o archivos que
están en manos de instancias de
seguridad nacional En este sentido
también advierten que la unidad especial
de investigación y litigación del caso
Ayotzinapa ha visto entorpecida su labor
Pues no ha tenido el mismo acceso a la
información que sí tienen por ejemplo la
comisión presidencial para el acceso a
la verdad y el propio Hey establecen que
es necesario profundizar en la
responsabilidad penal por el delito de
desaparición forzada con especial
énfasis en la cadena de Mando política
militar y de instancia de seguridad
civil recomiendan establecer una
política de comunicación que evite la
contradicción en la que han incurrido
las distintas instancias también
Proponen que sea un solo juzgado el que
tenga conocimiento de los distintos
procesos relacionados en el caso
ayotzina las integrantes de la cidh en
conferencia de prensa en la Escuela
Normal Rural Raúl Isidro burdes de
Ayotzinapa refrendaron su compromiso
para acompañar a los a los familiares a
los padres de los estudiantes en la
búsqueda de justicia y acceso a la
verdad establecieron que el caso de la
desaparición de los 43 normalistas no es
aislado que se da en un contexto de
constante violación en los derechos
humanos en Guerrero y en un país en el
que hay más de 100.000 personas
reportadas como desaparecidas y 52.000
el cuerpos aún no identificados
y en medio de las preocupaciones
climáticas globales nuevamente
activistas intentan llamar la atención
sobre la emergencia planetaria lanzando
pinturas sobre obras de arte esta vez el
escenario de la acción fue el museo
leopold de Viena Austria los activistas
del grupo Last generation echaron
pintura negra sobre la obra muerte y
vida de gustav klim y pegaron sus manos
al vidrio que protege el cuadro los
activistas detenidos por las autoridades
pedían detener los proyectos de
explotación de gas y petróleo que según
dijeron son una sentencia de muerte para
la humanidad
así llegamos al final de esta edición
sigan con nosotros en Frank 34 y 24.com
[Música]